hey Leute mein Name ist Laser Luca und
ganz herzlich willkommen zu der
allerersten Folge Wer wird Millionär das
wird ja nur eine geben erste letzte
Folge Wer wird Millionär normal oder
einfach
normal einfach normal
wir werden nicht von diesen Millionen
sehen uns bei 20 €. ich werde diese
Fragen so handhaben wie mein Unternehmen
wie ein Boss scheiße ich glaube wir
schaffen immer 50 was kommt traditionell
zu Sauerkraut auf den Tisch Eisbein
Eisbein ja sicher Eisbein ja ist das
Ihre Antwort ja das ist definitiv meine
Antwort in Ordnung der Computer hat ihre
Antwort bestätigt
und genauso ist es 50 Euro in meine Zeit
nicht nein wer hätte jetzt jeder 25 wie
lautet ein Oberbegriff für maschenstoffe
der Herren und Damenbekleidung Texel
Pellworm die Usedom
Jersey sicher nicht Pellworm Jersey
sicher ja also usedom ist auf jeden Fall
eine Stadt Deutschland
[Musik]
auf jeden Fall London Liverpool
Manchester wenn jetzt nicht London kommt
dann sind am Arsch London okay es ist
auf jeden Fall London entscheiden
weil ich in der Hose
in diesem Sinne
nachzudenken
was gibt's beim
Bäckerei
jetzt kommt die Folge von mir hören aber
auch mal lange nicht einfach jetzt
richtig ist notiert und wird als richtig
durchgehängt prima 500 Euro wenn wir
spielen auch normal ne 300 €. okay
welches Tier hat bei der WM 2010 7
Ergebnisse richtig vorher gesagt Giraffe
Oktopus oktoprocodil oder Schlange
Octopus war der Oktopus und da haben wir
die Sicherheitsstufe geknackt
welche Beziehung bezieht sich nicht auf
die Verpackung
Dosen Erbsen Büchsenmilch Flaschen
Kürbis oder Tütensuppe also es gibt auf
jeden Fall Dosen Erbsen ja aber welche
Bezeichnung ja
Büchsenmilch Flaschenkürbis die können
wir könnten einen Joker nehmen sollen
wir machen ja wollen wir Telefonjoker
nehmen welche Bezeichnung bezieht sich
nicht auf die Verpackung Dosen Erbsen
Büchsenmilch Flaschenkürbis oder
Tütensuppe
was keine Ahnung
nein
10 Sekunden Dosen erbsenbüchsenmilch
oder Flaschen Kürbis was gibt es nicht
schaffen
überzeugt wir wissen es nicht definitiv
meine Antwort in der falsche schauen wir
uns mal die richtige Antwort an
wie viele Wochen liegen zwischen Ostern
und Pfingsten drei Wochen fünf Wochen
sieben Wochen oder 9 Wochen also klar
und D auf gar keinen Fall drei Wochen
ist viel zu nah dran und 9 Wochen zu
weit weg wann ist Pfingsten immer Mai
und das andere ist im April Pfingsten
juni Wochenende dann fünf Wochen ja fünf
Wochen fünf Wochen fünf Wochen sicher
ich würde natürlich sagen
ja wir haben schon eingeloggt oder
wollen wir noch einen Joker nehmen
es müssen fünf Wochen sein sicher ist
definitiv meine Antwort auf jeden Fall
ist es entweder B oder C ein Wahrheit
ist getroffen
und das ist leider die falsche Antwort
sie haben verloren oh Mann ist das
peinlich
immerhin haben sie noch den Gewinn der
Sicherheitsstufe öffentlich zu sehr
ärgern
wir spielen jetzt noch mal eine Runde
allerdings nur mit den Kategorien
Geographie und Wissenschaft weil wir
beiden extrem gut darin sind ja ich
würde auch noch Geschichte reinpacken
der sieht doch so kryptisch aus ne
welche Kohl gibt es wirklich Rosenkohl
nein Rosenkohl
sind sie sich sicher ja das ist
definitiv gut
[Applaus]
welche Märchen Märchen might muss
regelmäßig ihr 20 ellenlanges Haar
herunterlassen Rapunzel Rapunzel ich
muss sie Fragen sind sie sich sicher ja
das ist definitiv eine Antwort es könnte
aber natürlich die transfunzel sein das
ist absolut richtig
so kleine Blasen im Mund
diese neue Frage sollte es Ihnen nicht
schwer machen jetzt so so nicht nach dem
Bus ja welcher das auch sowas wie du das
kannst du doch weil du so eine große
Nase hast
für welcher dieser Dinosaurier besaß
drei Hörner zu Hause
Stegosaurus oder trizadresse
ja
keine Ahnung
das ist definitiv meine Antwort oder das
ist der Stegosaurus genau
muss es sein ist es auch wir müssen doch
jetzt auf jeden Fall mit mit Joker ein
bisschen hantieren wer steht Sherlock
Holmes mit Rad und Tat zur Seite
entscheide mich für dich ist notiert und
wird als richtig durchgewinkt prima
Osiris war ein Gott welcher Mythologie
griechisch römisch ägyptisch Kälte die
frage ich ja nicht weiter
komm lass Telefon anders an
ganz schnell Sand und ich sind gerade
bei Wer wird Millionär du bist unser
Telefonjoker Osiris war ein Gott welcher
Mythologie griechisch römisch ägyptisch
oder kältetisch
keine Ahnung Osiris
Osiris Firat es geht hier gerade um
10.000 Euro es geht um 300 Euro aber gut
griechisch römische ägyptische oder
keltisch wir haben noch drei Sekunden
vier Grad
wir müssen noch einen Joker nehmen
glaube ich
ich vertraue da auch nicht auf keine
Ahnung bitte räumen sie jeden Zweifel
aus dem Weg und antworten Sie wenn Sie
die richtige Antwort kennen
[Musik]
was okay Firat hatte glaube ich doch
recht
wenn das jetzt falsch ist ne
gender-spiel aber wenn es richtig ist
hat Vierer der eine übelste Ahnung die
Spannung ist unerträglich ja dann mit
dieser Sicherheitsstufe haben Sie sich
schon mal einen Gewinn Übersicht
welcher Baum zählt zu den Nadelhölzern
Eibe Eiche Erle Esche
nadelholzen ich bin 55 Joker ich habe
eine Eichel in der Hose
da muss die Esche sein
Esche ich weiß das Essen Baumes okay ich
werde die das klingt für mich irgendwie
richtig
sie scheinen von ihrer Antwort überzeugt
zu sein aber sind sie sich sicher das
ist definitiv meine Antwort Sandra kennt
eine Esche deswegen muss es das sein die
richtige Antwort herauszufinden wenn wir
jetzt verkackten Schutz mir 500 Euro
so leid es mir auch tut dies ist nicht
die richtige Antwort oh Mann ist das
peinlich
an der Stelle würden Sanne und ich Wer
wird Millionär jetzt auch beenden meine
lieben Freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat
dann lasst gerne einen Daumen hoch unter
diesem Video hier da abonniert meinen
Kanal und klickt auf die Glocke um
weitere Videos nicht zu verpassen sandra
ist nicht in der Beschreibung verlinkt
danke
wenigstens mal insta für heute Boys ja
okay so heißt sie auf insta